hñ day one here I feel good how do you
feel alright good so I'll see you later
oh where you going if you yell please
alright
she's going off to do some things I'm
going to do some things but I'll see you
at the meetup right
Oh No all right first thing of the day
I'm doing a little hosting here for the
YouTube brand lab and yeah me one day we
made it
you guys want to see in the process to
get here it was insane we're like when
all these crazy different ways and over
here you guys do make sure children be
ran into today so I'm not only really
excited to be here today I'm thrilled
that all of you guys are here at VidCon
to to experience firsthand
I'm so amazingly blessed to experience
every day
now all of these fans have in this
incredible community of YouTube creators
it's just something I can watch do like
you a
let's do this
avatar behind-the-scenes vlogging as
usual so if he doesn t think bad blame
paya she would say I don't know okay
sometimes you say some things went long
sorry
so different
while turning into
everything I did
vish that's not with my QA and I ran
into Jenna goodness so fancy seeing you
here
busy seeing you here now we're about to
do our Meetup I'm pretty excited to see
everybody and yeah I think I'm actually
supposed to be out there right now but
but I'm not there's an ad in the back oh
this is so sunny I was right about it
yesterday and I couldn't find here I
just magically turned to the page look
at this guy's
you don't have one yet no oh you can
have that one I'll sell to you
I went thank you
I went shopping about four black
t-shirts holy-moly however this is the
cover so you guys got to go get one take
a selfie with it
Thank You website you reckon
you could finally put all of your phones
in there right now this is amazing
person sharpie and the may scanned it
and made it into a foil look at this
vlogging the g7x man it's a great do you
like it yeah I love it so far he
recommended a jumper jumper where you'll
find it you it will find it we said
stuff to somebody that was like and have
you ever signed a face and I was like no
I actually have not sign up it's gonna
be the first time yeah all right is this
allowed do you guys mind if I vlog it is
well you better what you have to give me
here I can do this all right
oh my god you see you nice game ah I
hope that comes off don't worry it's if
it's a scar I'm blessed
really hello
- Hannah's biggest fan I'm kind of
fangirling hello oh my gosh I get me you
hear me great fantastic we'll be doing
today we're done cool the rule all
questions to you guys to mrs. SS oh
hello giving some prizes I like okay
cool okay I am so excited
today's been so crazy but I am about to
interview Oh none other than Ohio so
Chyna I think about an item you think of
any questions that's what we're going to
do it's going to be great because first
even winning yeah alright so excited so
yeah you guys let's check out the
interview oh we're doing Tony pull at
him so excited so I'm gonna do down
everywhere I've been vlogging everybody
who has the g7x today there's some
grades look at this here this always a
friend oh you're filming in the 60
frames a second mode oh yeah very nice
how could you not I'm not to the right
of the g7x at 60 frames a second is to
deny I don't have anything no Lions real
cinematic yeah I don't really just like
you never know who you're gonna run into
here it's crazy yeah glad your eyes are
so good
wait that's that's great hahaha more
people need to get rid of theirs want to
make sure this window my snacks yeah
spotted another g7s no sure that you
have it that I have it the I love
exception okay so you're filming in 60
I'm still doing in 30 up what is it what
is that gonna do
you'll know the design much yes but I
just seen another youtuber what's up
cameras we show it's great so we're here
at VidCon 2015 can you believe it I
can't believe it in the first VidCon we
all sat in a lobby hung out with like 20
youtubers now it's like 20,000 20,000
it's kind of amazing
oh yeah it's so much fun yeah I'm just
doing what that brings
VidCon day ones are closed I'm going to
bed I think it's like 10 o'clock right
now doesn't really matter I'm tired I've
had so much fun meeting all you guys
today it was just it's always so much
fun game to see you and pour a little
Jen over there's not feeling well all
right I'll see you guys tomorrow I love
you bye hey guys today we're gonna we
had a busy day today it's actually not
that busy but I am preparing for VidCon